Did you know that you are made of trillions of cells
but only around 200 different types?
For example, the cells inside your cheek
are made up of stratified
squamous
epithelium cells
designed to handle constant abrasion.
These type of cells are not only in your cheeks, but also in your vagina and
anus as well.
Hey guys, I'm Christine Sydelko and I'm here with ASAP Science and we're talking about why your body is amazing
and mine is amazinger.
When you are an embryo, the first opening that developed was
your anus.
That's right, you were once just a butthole.
That means you are a Deuterostome
and so is a sea urchin.
Christine how much gas do you think exist in your anus in one day
Science says that today about half a liter of gas exist in your anus
and I say that too, I just said it
If it feels like too much, don't worry as your brain already
does a pretty good job of censoring content. Like your nose
Your nose is
The region that is blocked by the one eye is visible
for the other eye, and the brain constructs a
unified image and therefore you ignore your nose
but your nose is so powerful. In fact
if you convert your nose receptor neurones into binary code
it's the equivalent of 46 petabytes
that's more information than every movie
ever made after 2017. Convert all the cells in
your body and will add up to
91.44 zettabytes
or 10^21 bytes. Scientist hypothesized that during
pregnancy you gave some cells to your mum
I just gave gratitude
This process is called Fetal Maternal...
Microchimerism. I think I
I got it. This process is called Fetal Maternal Micro...
micro...michimisism
Microchimerism. Microsoft
Scientists has found fetal cells and various maternal tissues
that can persist for decades. The reason for this is unclear
but one hypothesis is that the baby is trying to increase
its chance of survival. When your heart stops, your brain actually
knows that you're dead. A study that investigated